bonjour à tous et d'abord bravo bravo
aux organisateurs bravo à daniel qui a
réussi à faire de ce rendez-vous un
incontournable à toute l'équipe autour
de lui
philippe rapeneau simon jambes à antoine
sylla niveau à nos nouveaux élus barry
monnier jeffrey cavallino bravo et
soutien à tous ceux qui s'engagent dans
les élections régionales dans cette
grande région sur laquelle on compte
beaucoup autour de xavier bertrand on a
entendu tout à l'heure marc philippe
daubresse
bernard gérard gérald darmanin ils sont
nombreux ici des jeunes élus d ébut plus
expérimentés dont on sent bien qu'ils
mettent toute leur énergie et portent
toutes nos espérances
dans cette campagne et autour d'eux on
soutient un nombre impressionnant d'élus
et de parlementaires edouard courtial
devant moi constance le grip jean
charles taugourdeau alain joyandet
damien meslot pierre charon ou georges
fenech
philippe juvin jeu françoise grossetête
jeu j'arrive constance me fait des
signaux comme ça du sémaphore merci
pierre g c'est un campus des jeunes
donc j'ai prévu de vous parler de la
jeunesse tout saluant l'arrivée de
philippe goujon député de paris et jan
vanhevel tête de liste à paris
vous avez quand on commence on n'arrête
pas marie-anne montchamp merci d'être là
et philippe cochet qui s'occupe de nos
nominations au sud de la loire
je ne sais pas si notre notre équivalent
au nord et là ils sont tous là j'ai
prévu jolivettes vous parlez la jeunesse
parce que c'est un campus des jeunes
merci
bayal un sondage ya quelques jours qui
annonçait qu'au primaire ce serait les
retraités qui voteraient est plutôt les
retraités et pour faire simple
alors finalement c'est pas très original
parce que moi depuis j'ai commencé la
politique j'entends dire ça j'entends
dire tu parles l'écologie a droit tout
le monde s'en moque
tu parles du monde d'après la
transformation numérique comme bernard
tout à l'heure et notre public n'a pas
dépassé le stade du mulot référence
plein d'affection néanmoins au mulot tu
parles aux jeunes et les jeunes ne
votent pas et je crois pas qu'il faille
céder à ce discours d'abord parce qu'il
ya pas de fatalité et ensuite parce que
la jeunesse nouveau monde des sujets
émergents en fait ça concerne tout le
monde quand la jeunesse trouve pas de
travail c'est toute la société qui en
échec coach national s'est convaincu que
son avenir est ailleurs c'est le pays
entier qui n'a pas d'avenir
on parle beaucoup d'immigration et on a
raison il ya de bons motifs
il ya même des motifs nouveau est
particulièrement dramatique mais je
voudrais vous parler des migrations
immigration quand on part je voudrais
vous parler de ceux de plus en plus
nombreux de plus en plus divers aussi
qui émigrent ou qu'ils y songent de
toute une jeunesse qui se demande s'il
va pas falloir partir ailleurs voir si
le marché du travail serait pas plus
dynamiques voir si la société serait pas
plus ouverte
voir finalement si l'humeur serait pas
plus optimiste car c'est un mouvement
qui existe et chacun d'eux c'est chacun
200 dans son entourage dans sa famille
même dans sa vie et je suis sûr qu'on
peut si on posait la question aux jeunes
qui sont là ils seraient nombreux à dire
qu'ils y ont pensé à dire qu'ils ont
autour d'eux des gens qui ont songé ou
qu'il en fait c'est le désir d'ailleurs
d'une jeunesse d
musée qui se demandent si l'herbe est
plus verte
finalement plus loin il y avait un
sondage en 2013 qui disait que 51% des
25-35 ans s'il le pouvait quitterait la
france 51% plus de la moitié des 25 35
ans ils le pouvaient quitterait la
france et c'est déjà le cas d'un diplômé
sur cinq issus des grandes écoles de
commerce c'est une perte de productivité
une perte sèche pour la france mes chers
amis c'est une aversion historique
la france n'a pas connu à travers son
histoire de grand mouvement d'émigration
ça n'est pas un pays qu'on quitte ça
nous est particulier dans presque tous
les pays européens il ya eu des vagues
d'émigration en italie en espagne au
portugal en irlande même en allemagne il
ya eu à d'autres moments de l'histoire
parfois des vagues d'émigration mais pas
en france et je parle pas des migrations
fiscale l'émigration fiscale elle existe
c'est une saignée
mais là c'est autre chose parce que les
jeunes qui partent à londres en
amériques en asie pour réussir autrement
ils n'ont pas de motif fiscal à émigrer
ils ont fait fortune à protéger ils
n'ont pas de fortune à transmettre
alors pourquoi est-ce qu'ils partent
pourquoi les jeunes partent eut-il ou
envisage-t-il de partir pour plus de la
moitié d'entre eux comme je le montrais
tout à l'heure ils partent parce que le
contrat moral entre les générations est
rompu depuis longtemps pendant longtemps
chaque génération a pensé que la
suivante vivrait mieux et c'était même
la justification de beaucoup d efforts
qu'on faisait on faisait des efforts
pour que les enfants vivent mieux un
jour et ça c'est fini
quand on pose la question
pensez vous que les jeunes d'aujourd'hui
auront plus autant ou moins de chance de
réussir que leurs parents dans la
société française de demain à une
enquête de janvier 2015 c'est tout
récent il ya trois français sur quatre
qui répondent qu'ils auront moins de
chance et c'est nouveau
mes chers amis c'est le résultat de
trois ans de mandat de françois hollande
souvenez-vous en janvier 2012 c'était
son discours du bourget il lançait à ce
moment là à la france je le cite si je
reçois le mandat du pays d'être le
prochain président je ne veux être jugé
que sur un seul objectif est ce que les
jeunes vivront mieux en 2010 est qu'en
je demande à être évalué sur ce seul
engagement
mes chers amis je vous pose la question
trois ans plus tard les jeunes
est ce que vous vivez mieux vous d'y
être la priorité de son mandat
ben vous êtes aujourd'hui la grande
oubliée de son quinquennat
et ça mérite une sanction est un peu
plus la jeunesse elle part parce qu'ils
y croient plus c'est un signal d' alerte
ça concerne pas que les jeunes ça
concerne tout le monde l'exil c'est dur
pour ceux qui partent mais c'est encore
plus dur pour ceux qui restent parce que
quand les jeunes diplômés auront quitté
la france à la suite des grands
capitalistes qui étaient susceptibles
d'investir dans les startups qui
l'aurait créé et aurait plus ceux qui
avaient les idées ni ceux qui avaient
l'argent pour investir dans les idées
mais qu'est ce qui restera est-ce qu'il
faut se résigner
non est ce que le mouvement est
irréversible bien sûr que non ceux qui
partent ils aiment pas moins la france
il s'exile pas par plaisir d'avoir
beaucoup dans l'idée que la france peut
pas se réformer et ça c'est à nous de
leur démontrer le contraire ils veulent
pas rester pris au piège ils ont le
sentiment que c'est un piège
et puis il y en aura peu le ras-le-bol
de la sinistrose
finalement il applique le mode ten qui
disait en voyage pour changer
non pas de lieu mais d'idées ils ont
envie de changer d'idée voilà voilà
notre mission voilà notre rôle
voilà la clé changer d'idée en 2015 à
l'occasion des élections régionales en
à l'occasion des élections
présidentielles c'est possible je
parlais de la jeunesse n'est pas une
question d'âge ou alors c'est une
question d'âge des idées parce que les
idées aussi ont un âge elles sont d'une
génération il ya les idées des trente
glorieuses sont un peu passés il ya les
idées des années 90
quelle idée aujourd'hui on transformera
pas la france avec les idées des années
90 je prends un fil directeur
comme plusieurs de ce jeu les notés qui
se sont exprimées aujourd'hui comme de
nombreux d'entre eux mêmes la liberté
une idée neuve toujours 9es notamment
dans un pays dont les élites se sont
acharnés à multiplier les contraintes
ont déchaîné leur créativité pour
additionner toujours plus de contraintes
pour des années
deux idées à partager pour finir
l'entreprise française elle étouffe sous
les charges 120 milliards de
prélèvements en plus que sur les
entreprises allemandes
on voudrait que nous attendions d'avoir
résorber le déficit
pour nous en occuper bah c'est
inefficace parce que personne n'a jamais
vu qu'on résorbe un déficit sans
croissance
c'est injuste parce que ça veut dire
qu'on condamne la jeunesse au chômage le
temps qu'on ait résorber les dettes de
leurs aînés et puis ces mensonges et
parce que promettre des baisses d'impôts
pour plus tard en fait saigner arrivait
jamais nous avons besoin au même moment
du même mouvement et ça doit être un
projet pour 2010 est de baisser les
impôts les charges et de faire les
réformes de structure dont on a besoin
au premier rang desquels parce que c'est
aussi une question de justice pour la
jeunesse le passage de l'âge de la
retraite à 65 ans deuxième idée
le monde du travail se transforme il ya
un mouvement qu'il traverse d'
aspiration à la liberté
le développement de l'indépendance
l'auto-entreprise l'entreprise
individuelle le portage salarial ça
prend plusieurs formes
en tout cas dans la jeunesse avec le
numérique on a plus envie du lien de
subordination qui est dans l'essence du
salariat on n'aime plus trop les
hiérarchies avec les outils numériques à
une nouvelle société qui émergent dans
ce monde là les questions anciennes sont
un peu dépassées par exemple la durée du
travail les 35 heures ça n'a pas été une
chance pour la france
mais si c'est pour revenir à une durée
unique les 39 heures c'est pas la bonne
idée non plus est-ce que tout simplement
une durée du travail unique c'est pas
dépasser aujourd'hui à l'heure où on
sent comme ça dans l'économie dans la
société
un mouvement de liberté j'ai pas faire
un catalogue de mesures je veux juste
partager une envie une envie de liberté
la liberté d'aller chercher des idées
neuves de pas rester prisonnier des
vieilles lunes personnes dans aucune
famille politique dans aucune aventure
humaine mes chers amis personnes les
forces il est d'abord libre et c'est le
propre de toutes les oeuvres collectives
que ceux qui les portent sont d'abord
des hommes et des femmes libres
je vous appelle ensemble à cultiver
notre liberté
tout simplement pour rendre la leur aux
français chers amis aujourd'hui demain
en 2015 et en 2017
soyons libres